Speaker 1: We've talked for a while now about
how the Republican Party has essentially abandoned
Speaker 2: policy, like in some
Speaker 1: vague way.
Taxes are bad and, you know, regulation is
bad.
But even since early in the Trump administration,
after the tax bill passed,
Speaker 2: the Republican Party stopped being
Speaker 1: about policy, but rather about
cultural issues.
I am going to show you now a fundraising email
sent out by Donald Trump's Save America PAC,
which has the closest thing to a policy platform
on it.
Trump lists a bunch of stuff almost like we
would list.
Well, we want to make sure everybody has
Speaker 2: access to health care.
We want to
Speaker 1: make sure that you're not going
to be killed by pollution and that emitters
of pollution are regulated.
And we want to make sure that people are paying
the right amount of taxes to properly fund
social services.
And here are the social policy, right?
Trump sends out a fundraising email that looks
like a policy list,
Speaker 2: but it's crazy.
Speaker 1: Look at this Trump.
You know Trump's not writing this, but it's
being sent down under Trump's name friend.
Have you noticed that the radical left is
now admitting I was right about everything
they lied about before the election?
And here's the list.
Hydroxychloroquine works now.
Hydroxychloroquine is a medication that
Speaker 2: works for some things.
No evidence.
Speaker 1: It works for COVID.
The China virus came from a Chinese lab that's
not been demonstrated.
Hunter Biden's laptop was real.
Well, it was a real laptop,
Speaker 2: or it was really
Speaker 1: hunter's or it really contained
the things you claim.
Again, this is like it's like a policy platform
of crazy.
Lafayette Square was not cleared for a photo
op.
In fact, we know that it was the Russian bounties
stories was fake.
It appears to have been real.
We did produce vaccines before the end of
2020 in record time.
OK, I mean,
Speaker 2: you know, that's one where it's
sort of
Speaker 1: what is being implied.
The Marina platform allows rapid vaccine production,
so when Trump says without me, it would have
taken 10 or 12 years now without Miranda.
Speaker 2: It might have taken seven, five
or seven or eight years.
Speaker 1: You had nothing to do with them
RNA, and that's why the vaccine
Speaker 2: was produced quickly.
Speaker 1: Blue state lockdowns didn't work.
You know, what's interesting about that is
they sort of did actually like early.
We had this situation
Speaker 2: where the COVID
Speaker 1: cases and deaths were disproportionately
happening in blue urban centers because those
were the places with the major airports flying
back
Speaker 2: and forth to China
Speaker 1: in Europe, where the virus was
brought to the United States from
Speaker 2: once vaccines became widely
Speaker 1: available.
Speaker 2: The case rate and the death
Speaker 1: rates in red states and in particular
in Trump counties way, way, way higher than
in Biden County.
So that's wrong.
Two schools should be reopened.
They basically are open because of Omicron.
Now, a few colleges have said we're going
back to remote, but basically schools are
open.
Critical race theory is a disaster for our
schools and our country, and our southern
border security program was unprecedentedly
successful.
Speaker 2: This is so funny because it's sort
of like
Speaker 1: a stupid person's policy
Speaker 2: platform.
It looks
Speaker 1: like policy.
There's really no policy like hydroxychloroquine
works.
It's a statement of fact.
It happens to be incomplete.
It works, but not for COVID.
But what's the policy behind it?
Speaker 2: And this
Speaker 1: seems to be, to some degree, a
reaction to realizing that we've got to have
something
Speaker 2: we're kind of running on
Speaker 1: to get people to give us money,
but we're going to make it really what is
at the end
Speaker 2: of the day, cultural stuff.
And the saddest
Speaker 1: thing about it is
Speaker 2: the Glenn Youngkin victory
Speaker 1: in Virginia shows us that this
Speaker 2: type of thing works.
Speaker 1: He ran against critical race theory
in Virginia, which was not even being taught
in Virginia schools,
Speaker 2: and he won.
Speaker 1: Terry McAuliffe made mistakes as
well, so this may be the closest we get to
a platform from Republicans.
It's a joke.
But.
Sadly, it might work, and that's why we've
got to really be ready for 2022.
Part of getting ready is we are going to try
to resuscitate declining membership numbers
Speaker 2: on January 1st.
Speaker 1: We'll be doing a one day membership
special.
It's going to be huge.
And if you'd like to be notified, just get
on our mailing list by signing up at David
Pakman dot com January 1st.
You'll get a beautiful email from me telling
you
Speaker 2: exactly how to sign up.
Speaker 1: Let's take a quick break and we'll
be right back after this.
The program that you are listening to right
now, we're watching right now, David Pakman
The David Pakman Show, is primarily funded
by viewers and listeners who sign up on my
website and get a yearly or monthly membership.
These memberships come with very powerful
benefits, including a daily extra show, as
well as access to commercial free audio and
video streams of the shows and so many other
great things.
Sign up at join
Speaker 2: Packman dot com!